[music playing]
MAN: We are here to
document the lives
of people living in Alaska.
The harsh reality is the
environment we're up against.
It makes it tough to do our job.
NATHANIEL "NATCHO"
STEPHENS: Get out of there.
MAN: Working on "Life Below
Zero" can be very dangerous.
MAN: Gun's here.
Camera's here.
MAN: Never know what to expect.
MAN: Whoa!
Did you [bleep]
see that [bleep]??
MAN: Gonna be tough, but
we're going to get the shot.
MAN: Every scenario, we
gotta prepare for this.
NATHANIEL "NATCHO" STEPHENS:
But we're still smiling.
We're having fun.
Still making "Life Below Zero."
Yes.
Bring it on.
So of all the
things that we do
working on "Life Below
Zero," I would say this
is one of the most challenging.
It's our travel day to the
Hailstones Kiwalik Camp.
The biggest challenge
is getting out there.
We can only get
to about 100 miles
away from where
we're going by plane.
And then the rest of the way,
we need to go on snow machines,
hauling sleds with
some of our gear.
We are right at the
edge of the peninsula.
So we'll be traveling over
sea ice for the next 40 miles.
The ice is very dynamic
out here on the ocean.
It's breaking and
coming together.
It's being moved by the
tides and by the winds.
And it's a little bit dangerous.
But we mitigate those
dangers by making a good plan
and taking our time and being
thoughtful about how we travel.
All right, boys.
You ready for this?
Let's do it!
NATHANIEL "NATCHO"
STEPHENS: Yes.
So we're right on target.
We've got a couple
hours of daylight left.
And it looks like we should
be fine to get into camp
and make some shelter
before it's totally dark.
It's incredible that
we get to do this,
that this is our job, riding
across the Arctic Ocean.
And we're really
feeling lucky right now.
MAN: We arrived here just
before dark last night,
after our 100 mile trip.
NATHANIEL "NATCHO" STEPHENS:
So when we got in last night,
it was all we could do to just
get shelter up, basically,
and get the things
that we needed
to get a decent night's sleep.
We've got a home
that's relatively
comfortable, relatively warm.
Now, it's time to organize
and settle in so that we
can be ready for filming.
ROB POLLARD: Anyone
that works on this show,
you can't be complacent.
You need to prepare
properly every time you go
in something bad could happen.
You don't want to be out
there in a sticky situation.
Here we are, in Dead
Horse, inside the hangar.
We're going into Kavik.
Sue hasn't been at Kavik
for quite a bit of time.
So we're going to go in
planning for the worse,
hoping for the best
when we get there.
We have quite a bit of
camera equipment here.
A show like "Life
Below Zero" requires us
to travel with a lot of gear.
This isn't your standard show
where you can drive in a car,
get to set, and start shooting.
We're going in not knowing
what we're going to get into.
So we go as prepared
as possible.
We don't know what
to expect at camp.
So we've got full GoPros rigged.
My focus is always on trying to
capture what we expect to see.
And that is going to be--
we're going to be flying
over the camp to check it out.
So we've got a
camera looking down,
camera on the wing looking
at her as she's driving.
And then obviously her as
she's looking out the window.
We can't get in there.
So it's just going to be GoPros.
We just enjoy the ride.
MAN: Our number one
concern is safety--
everything is safe and
everyone is safe-- so that we
can continue doing our work.
BRAD CARPER: Personal
gear is over here, guys.
So we're going out to
Andy [inaudible] place.
I'm really excited
to go out there.
But there's a lot of
logistics involved
with getting to Andy's.
We start in Fairbanks.
We fly to Eagle
on a small plane.
And then they basically-- we
put all of our stuff here.
And then we get on an
even smaller plane.
And then we just
do multiple trips
for about five or six hours
until everything's out there.
Then we get on snow
machines, sleds.
And we basically haul everything
to our cabins and get set up.
But the main thing here is
that when you're filming people
living off the grid, we have
to live off the grid too.
in order to really
capture that story,
we have to live that life.
So right here, we
basically have all
of our food items, our camera
gear, fuel here for cooking.
We're in a very remote place,
so we kind of have to be self
sustainable from the beginning.
Oh, man, this is a tight space.
Woo!
It's tiny.
Smaller than the outhouse
I'm gonna be using.
This is where we're going.
We're gonna land on
this lake down here.
It's a very windy area.
There's a lot of
mountain terrain.
There's low trees.
And then he
basically has to make
a perfect landing on this lake.
And it's just
complete glare ice.
So it was a really
bumpy landing.
But we're here.
Then the real work begins.
The way we get the true story.
We're not living in a hotel.
I mean, we are literally
in a remote place.
And in order to capture
that true story,
we have to live
that lifestyle too.
It's time to go live off
the grid for a little bit.